(singing)
(whistling)
- Kiss.
- Kiss, come on.
- What are you guys doing?
Jeez, this is my dog.
Stop trying to make my dogs make out.
- What?
Ya'll got fat asses.
I'm Hercules bitch.
- Kieth, you are not in the band.
- No but you guy are gonna Poca want this.
- We do not Poca want this.
- You gotta Poca try,
give a Pocca try this.
- Where's Peter?
- I'm the hero Neverland deserves.
But not the one it needs right now.
- Shut up Eugene.
- No, no, don't touch me.
My fins are swollen and I want some clams.
- Don't you want to be
where the people are?
- No, I wanna be on the ocean floor.
(screams)
♫ I've got the thai food,
I've got the thai food ♫
- Get out of our video.
Give me that.
- No, no.
(yelling)
- Can we make sure the
doors are locked please?
- What?
- I thought you knew,
that's why I wear such billowy pants.
Because of my diaper.
- Oh my God, get off my carpet.
- You don't, okay.
- Did you just do it right now?
- No, sorry.
Call me.
- No, I won't.
- Wait, what are you guys doing?
- Kiss.
- Stop it.
Don't make my dogs kiss.
So weird.
- We can't do let it go.
- It doesn't sound like that at all.
- No, it does.
- Everyone knows every word to this song.
- She enunciates really well.
- But Frozen is my favorite--
- Let it go.
- What?
No, no.
Come on guys, come on.
- Run, run, run.
- I mean it is the middle of the night.
And on my table?
I eat here.
♫ Please let me into the group ♫
- Go home Kieth.
♫ Salad and gouda, chicken tabboulleh ♫
- Tabboulleh, tabboulleh.
Bippity, boppity, boo.
(crying)
- Andy's coming.
- Aha!
What?
I swore I heard something.
What is wrong with me?